[Música]
[Aplausos]
y sucedió
[Música]
muy lineal mismo de funciones line y
vascas
julen
y ya
[Música]
y me paro
primero
yo a la vieja
no
[Música]
mi mentalidad
dos de las cualidades importantes para
componer una canción son el escuchar y
el observar yo tengo la dicha de haber
nacido con una cualidad innata que se
llama oído absoluto u oído perfecto y
esta estabilidad está ubicada en el
cerebelo y hoy lo que soto significa el
tener la habilidad de escuchar música y
saber qué notas están sonando qué
acordes están sonando qué ritmos están
adentro de la batería del bajo que nos
están diciendo los acordes del piano qué
notas tiene la melodía sin necesidad de
tener un instrumento de referencia
entonces estabilidad me me ha ayudado a
meterme a la música en distintas
profundidades de las que vamos a hablar
más adelante
y bueno se dice que una de cada 10.000
personas nace con esta habilidad es algo
bastante especial que de verdad me ayudó
mucho a meterme a la música varios
artistas hay muchísimos artistas
que han estado en la escena de la música
alrededor de la historia que también ha
sido con oído absoluto
geimer con michael jackson el aficionado
y frank sinatra se dan cuenta que son
personalidades bastante famosas verdad
tal vez no sabemos mucho de eso pero
tener esta habilidad hace que la carrera
musical sea algo un poquito más sencillo
en cuanto a manejarse adentro de verdad
obviamente después de tener esta
habilidad
hay que aprender a escribir música hay
que aprender a armonía hay que aprender
digamos todas las partes teóricas de la
música para que esta habilidad crezca
entonces bueno esta habilidad musical a
mí me ha ayudado a ver la música a
distintas profundidades como les decía y
quisiera comprarlo a la escala de
colores aquí tenemos la paleta completa
de colores cuando este disco gira pues
tenemos el color blanco verdad entonces
bueno la música se puede ubicar en
distintos lugares a mi punto de vista
pero todo depende de la perspectiva con
la que lo veamos es como bueno
imaginamos que yo quiero decorar este
cuarto y quiero decorarlo con tonos
terra sí entonces yo ya sé qué colores
voy a escoger de la escala cromática no
y será puede poder hacerlo con colores
pastel pueden hacerlo con otro tipo otra
paleta de colores distinta entonces
nosotros ya sabemos a dónde ubicarnos
este marco de decoración en la música lo
dan los instrumentos armónicos que es el
piano que tengo aquí a mi izquierda los
instrumentos armónicos nos dan el molde
con el que vamos a construir una canción
y esto es lo que hacen los acordes la
armonía es la que hace esta esta
situación
verdad obviamente pues otros colores
importantes les van a poner la sección
más rítmica de la música que son la
batería y el bajo y así cada uno va a
cortar con su perspectiva esto yo creo
que tiene un ejemplo a viario es
bastante cotidiano verdad por ejemplo
imaginemos que tenemos un problema o una
situación a abordar hay gente que lo ve
con colores distintos no hay gente que
aborda problemas con un rojo ocasional
el verbal y se pone estresado pero hay
gente que no aborda problemas con un
color verde con un color más pacífico
más calma con un celeste entonces en
música también yo puedo crear esas
sensaciones y dar esas profundidades
solo ubicando algo en un color
específico
un ejemplo que a mí me gusta muchísimo
hacer la canción de cono yo creo que es
una canción conocida a nivel mundial y
todas las que somos mamás tal vez en
algún punto la hemos usado para arrollar
a nuestros hijos esta canción se ubica
en un color verde claro que genera esa
sensación de paz de serenidad verdad
algunas personas que pueden ubicar en un
tono rosado pastel algunas personas en
un color amarillo claro también pero
todo tiene una teoría verdad realmente
este color es el que genera un poco la
sensación de serenidad en general
entonces ahí es donde ubicamos esta
canción ya todos la conocemos pero yo
creo que la letra va a depender mucho de
que le cantamos nosotros a nuestros
hijos yo creo que cada mamá tiene su
letra distinta verdad
a dormir
a dormir a dormir mi bebito que tus
sueños sean siempre de amor cariño y
pasa a morir a dormir que los ángeles
van a cantar a cuidarte para que duerma
se va
qué pasaría si yo le pongo una batería
de rockera a esta canción verdad en qué
color se ubicaría esta canción ya no
sería un verde pálida sí ahora yo me
tuve una libertad hace algún tiempo de
presentar un arreglo de esta canción en
un concierto que tuvimos con mi cuarteto
y mucho
y presentamos un arreglo armónico que es
como la palabra a la que me quiero
enfocar al molde al punto de vista de la
perspectiva este arreglo pues lo tocamos
en una versión un poco latina verdad un
poco chacha y le cambiamos el molde los
acordes si es como también me decía un
ejemplo por ahí verdad imagínense que
quiero hacer una gelatina ya tengo el
sabor yo tengo el color pero la pongo en
un molde de osito o en un molde de forma
de lado puedo poner las nobles distintos
pero va a seguir siendo la misma cosa
verdad la cuestión es cómo lo voy a
presentar y el arreglo pues nos quedó
algo así
a dormir a dormir a dormir mi bebito que
tus sueños sean siempre de amor cariño y
paz
[Música]
bebé que los ángeles pan
cantante y cuidarte para que duermas
[Música]
otro punto de vista para mí fue otro
color totalmente distinto para mí se
oscureció tal vez un poco no está tan
pastel y yo bajo mi perspectiva lo
viniera en ese punto exactamente eso es
lo que hace la música brazo es lo que
realmente hace los acordes para nosotros
usted suena a un intento de ellas porque
escogí yó ella es como una profesión
como un modo de vida yo creo que el jazz
es un es un género musical bastante
amplio bastante complejo entonces
nosotros podemos expresar la libertad
bajo diversas líneas bajo diversos
colores la libertad la podemos demostrar
no sólo haciendo música digamos en
distintos sub géneros del jazz sino
también haciendo aportes cada uno es
como literalmente va a trabajar en
equipo de alguna empresa o tener gente a
nuestro cuidado verdad nosotros cuatro
trabajamos en equipo y hacemos que la
música suene de la forma en la que suena
cada quien aporta su color cada quien
aporta su forma distinta de ver las
cosas
el jazz es así es muy genérico verdad
nosotros lo podemos ubicar y a veces
puede ser que el jazz suene poco
digerible pero realmente depende del
punto de vista en el que estamos en ese
momento también depende mucho de los
sentimientos hay gente que es muy
visceral para reaccionar verdad hay
gente que es muy calma para reaccionar
el jazz también es así el jazz puede
tener distintos ambientes distintos
estados de ánimo pero todo depende de la
forma en que yo lo escuché y la forma en
que yo reaccioné adentro de la música un
ejemplo que a mí me gusta también
bastante
es una canción de 20 richards el
pianista del cantante compositor autor
más conocido por la función que hizo
entre el blues y el gospel de hecho fue
muy criticado por eso yo creo que
algunos tal vez ya vieron una película
de su vida verdad muy criticado pero
también con un carácter bastante
aguerrido y una de las cosas que me
gusta de él es eso de verdad la pasión
con la que él compuso toda su música
entonces han escuchado tema your own
nómico young es un tema de blues y le
decimos nosotros verdad un tema muy
blues pero lo que tiene este tema es que
mientras la letra se va desarrollando
vamos ubicando
en distintos puntos el enfoque del color
si por ejemplo la letra dice me das tu
mano te acercas a mí yo me pongo
nerviosa me pongo a temblar y cualquiera
diría que me conoces bien pero realmente
no me conoces eso dice la letra no tú no
conoces a la persona que sueña despierta
contigo que lenta
a besar tus labios que le encantaría
abrazarte fuerte pero yo soy solamente
una amiga y es lo único que voy a hacer
porque tú no me conoces eso dice la
letra es un reclamo no es un reclamo
violento es un reclamo pasión pero al
final de cuentas bastante es mucho
sentimiento entonces por eso es que a mi
punto de vista tiene distintas partes de
ahora dependiendo de lo que vaya
diciendo la letra entonces voy a chávez
tenía esta peculiaridad él nos podía
mover de un espectro de un lugar del
espectro a otro si la canción pues dice
así
education
[Aplausos]
en ese entonces
manjares persas
y un amigo
[Música]
y
otra opción
[Música]
y que se hable
soy
para aprender más
[Música]
y concluye
siga
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es mi plan
a freír
[Música]
este año se va
muy fácil
o más joven y sana
sí
todo mal
[Música]
sí
distintos momentos en cada momento me
tira a un color sí sí tenemos una
perspectiva amplia y si sabemos ver qué
está pasando alrededor yo creo que
podrían salir las mejores composiciones
los mejores proyectos por eso es que me
encanta mucho comparar a la música con
el espectro de luz porque nos da
distintos puntos de vista
tres mujeres que a mí me han inspirado
que me inspiran siempre para cantar para
tocar para componer música son mujeres
que están representadas por una palabra
si nina simone por ejemplo nina simone
para mí representa el empoderamiento si
se dan cuenta el tiempo del que ella
estuvo con nosotros pues ella vivió una
transición muy bueno vivió la transición
de la esclavitud de la raza negra no
entonces ella las composiciones que ella
hacía eran muy viscerales ella observó y
escuchó lo que estaba pasando en el
momento social en el que ella vivió y la
mayoría de sus composiciones incluso la
forma en que ella canta la forma en que
ella toca el piano es impresionante
ahora hay mucha energía yo diría que hay
muchísimos colores con tonos oscuros
pero rojo oscuro un cafecito por ahí lo
que sale el rojo no en el afis gerald él
era bastante versátil vivió una época
similar pero el estilo de vida de la fue
un poco distinto no tanto
lo importante de ella y lo que más
sobresale en su historia es que ella
tenía el rango al más amplio que
cualquier cantante lo ha tenido ella tal
vez no fue una compositora persona
intérprete de muchísimos estándares de
jazz muy conocidos a nivel mundial ella
trabaja de la mano con luisa maestro por
ejemplo también un trompetista que
cantaba
ella hizo bastantes arreglos también y
bueno lo bonito de ella era que ella
tenía los fundamentos tenía toda la
teoría muy clara pero cuando cantaba
hacía lo que quería y eso es lo más
importante verdad creo que es mucho más
importante tener en el equipo a un
músico que proponga y no músico que haga
lo que le lo que tiene que hacer no sé
si me explico con esto ahora yo creo que
es muy importante que todos aporten de
sus colores esto lo que hacía él a ella
aportaba muchísimo con esa versatilidad
vocal que tenía y esperanza spalding
esperanza spalding es ese contemporánea
mía yo también nací en el 84
ella pues yo la defino como una mujer
versátil
y como una mujer innovadora ella vino a
innovar lo que hoy en día es una racista
una mujer músico y es lo que a mí más me
gusta de ella ella es un músico
en todo el sentido de la palabra una
cantante bastante expresiva pero también
una contrabajista que conoce muy bien su
teoría es lo que más me gusta de
esperanzas para líbano estas tres
mujeres han trabajado de la mano conmigo
a lo largo de mi carrera como
compositora de jazz y creo que han
aportado un color muy especial a toda la
música que están otorgando al mundo esta
ilustración que ven acá fue hecha por el
bajista que me acompañó al esfero
gonzález y yo creo que abarca muchísimo
lo que nosotros somos somos seres llenos
de colores somos seres que podemos dar
luz y somos seres que podemos dar a la
oscuridad somos seres que podemos
afrontar alguna situación con puntos de
vista distintos pero al mismo tiempo
creo que este montón de colores que
nosotros tenemos nos pueden aportar
podemos nosotros aportar con estos
colores a las situaciones oa la empresa
en la que trabajemos o con la banda con
la que trabajemos
uno de ellos cada uno de ellos perdón
hoy está cortando hoy con su expertise
con la forma en la que toca su
instrumento por ejemplo acá tengo
izquierda victoria del priísta como el
que yo he trabajado todos estos años
espero gonzález en el bajo alejandro
arévalo en la batería ellos tres son
parte vital de este equipo qué pasaría
si alguno de ellos no aporta con
consciencia no aporta con todo el
expertise del caso con todo el
profesionalismo del caso de raya parte
de eso con creatividad yo creo que son
cosas bastante importantes para trabajar
en equipo
y bueno nosotros bueno yo hice una
canción para este evento desde que
estuvimos practicando de participar
enter
me inspiré muchísimo en una canción la
queremos presentar hoy por primera vez
es para ustedes espero que la disfruten
y la letra la letra es esta misma
canción que cante al principio solo que
ahora la van a escuchar distintas van a
escuchar como todos los músicos que
están aquí conmigo hoy van a aportar de
esa subjetividad de esa experiencia esos
colores que ellos tienen para ustedes
miembro de julio gracias
e
[Música]
aquí
where we ever y les notificará interplay
[Música]
nací en paz
pero esa aparición no es de sólo 15 años
[Música]
ciudad
rimando
[Música]
la verdad
primero
[Música]
d
de estas casas fin a esta tradición o
pertenecen
sólo quien sabe
p
i
mi meta
yo no
[Música]
tú
yo al adiós
primero
[Música]
d
e
[Música]
mi mente
y yo
[Música]
yo a nadie
tú
mi abuela
[Música]
ah
y nada
no
[Música]
ah